yeah okay let's get right into this is
already up against a tough time Google
good what number everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk apis owed three to seven of
the askgaryvee show and i'm excited
actually chase i think after we do this
you've got to be in the top three of
doing content with another human being
there are now at least four or five six
jam sessions that we've had true i think
speaks to our kinship i'm really excited
to have a chase
Jarvis on the show he has a new book
coming out I really feel like I'm
becoming the new kind of like Today Show
like I got hit up three times today by
people who I had really great like like
acquaintances subtle relationships with
back in early Twitter oh nine ten eleven
I think the word has gotten on the
street that being on this podcast sells
a shitload of books so that makes me
happy she says a new book he's a friend
he's an entrepreneur he's a creative
create or but what have I left out chase
for no man you know who you are
now you're crushing it just lifelong
photographer probably about photography
into starting creativeLIVE Greylock back
company ten years in the in the biz and
we got more than ten million people
using the platform it's a place to go to
learn creativity entrepreneurship from
the world's top experts people like
Branson Tim Ferriss Bernie Brown friends
of ours yeah I remember when you and I
did a event at a Javits Center mmm-hmm
which i think is like a famous iconic
photography event right yes the name of
it again
do you ever photo Plus Expo right so I
just remember I loved that talk that we
did together because it was in your
domain yeah
photo play and just watching the
admiration from so many people there for
you
oh well it helped me remember uh you
know a lot of times I go into the wine
world my sister just went on a trip to
Napa with her husband and Justin my
homey who works here and she and they
went with friends and their friends were
taken aback by how people reacted to me
because that was my world yeah and
that's the comp that I'm giving which is
it was awesome to see the admiration in
that community for you I mean really
that is we're you that's yes
right yeah that's my og story and part
of like and basically I did for
photography what you did for one yes
help people understand that the internet
was gonna change everything and that you
get a lot of pushback
Oh your earliest days of like saying
this is gonna be big Caleb are you a fan
like what you're really in this one like
tell me oh yeah this was this was the
first time that that that I have on
record that I and I've scoured the
Internet where people were paying me
behind the scenes to create on social
the campaign was actually secondary so
they were taking access to me and my
audience and I which I filtered very
carefully I will only connect brands to
my audience if there was a real
connection so some of the photography I
did the first ever campaign for the
camera that that now all of these
cameras shoot video the very first one
was the D 90 and I basically made a
video with that camera about the
campaign for that camera and it sold
more cameras than neck in it ever so
without doing anything a good friend of
mine and so I don't even want to go
there too long but like in a lot of ways
has a lot of nuances to Casey right yes
like right like when I think about him
coming from a movie you know kind of
thing like and then you know but there's
a very safe and to app you guys know
each other oh yeah oh yeah super super
well super well as a stretch I know each
other he's got me on his boosted boards
and all the stuff the case he does yeah
tries to risk our lives but I think
right now he's pretty quiet in LA I mean
I know I know what the plan was but like
I don't know what the executions been I
see des going yeah what's that right
where you talked about a bunch of stuff
right that one really well right they
got reference you talk about beam
because I think somebody breath yeah
somebody referenced it
yeah yeah it's being quiet for a little
bit I think you know you highlight
something probably interesting which is
where people throw in rocks when you
were sort of trying to reinvent the
photography industry and the answer is
yes I don't be too too dramatic but I
literally had death threats like you're
taking money out of my family's income
and you're putting it on the tables and
in the pockets of photographers who
don't know what they're doing I got
giving access not them today because
people don't think you should do work
for free and I still never understand
today death threats but if you know you
know that's I mean what is the Bezos
says you have to
willing to be misunderstood for long
periods of time and then well someday
you're right and that's my entire
framework of my life the same it's all I
believe in the same in the same the same
is true with photography early on then I
leverage that into oh no learning online
is actually gonna be a thing let's make
a hard picture because I've been
learning from interviewing lately my
strengths and weaknesses let's go right
hardcore into the book okay what's the
book about why'd you write it sure the
books about three things one every
person is creative I'm trying to rewrite
the narrative that art is not creativity
creativity is building businesses
writing code building a family basically
everything that we do we as humans are
creating machines it's the foundation
the different jet so can I jump in
because we love to yes has anyone ever
said no usually don't ask
and then everybody and everybody was
watching gets upset so I'm trying to not
be as hated um my team
Ryan Harwood when I bought pure Wow we
started gallery Media Group
d-roc Andy subtlety's from this
collective team I only in the last year
and a half have decided that I was super
creative
yep but see this segment wouldn't make
that connection which is why it's
powerful what you're saying yes I lived
it yeah I was so entrenched too I'm a
businessman right I did along the way in
the last decades say I'm creative in
that yeah now I just think I'm creative
yeah and and but saying you're creative
in something like just take the in
something actually think I'm the
greatest creative yeah person's not
surprised you say that you rock I'm in
the prop I will win an Academy Award and
I'm gonna say [ __ ] you do you rock I
told you go ahead yes so that you you
are the perfect case study right that
you were like I'm this and then over
time you realize no wait this is this is
creativity and right now a stay-at-home
dad a lawyer a concrete manufacturer
doesn't think they are but your point is
they are and I'm actually buying that
today yes and I don't know if I would
have seven years ago for sure and that's
what I'm trying to rewrite the culture
narrative about creativity so that's
thing one everyone's creative and I'm
gonna rewrite the narrative thing too is
that creativity is a muscle Maya
Angelou's like them it's like the
infinite resource the more you use the
more you have this is not surprising
right a muscles like anything you more
you use it stronger you get a hundred
percent I'm trying to get people to
acknowledge that creativity in point
and then cracks it yeah so and then
these three let me get them safe oh no
no that's good think three is that it's
in creating in small daily ways and
acknowledging that all the things that
you just talked about making and
creating everyday making that you
actually realize and you have agency
over creating your life it's just
creativity in higher scale I'm a brother
I'm a buyer when I tried to jump in on
number two for one reason cuz you
motivated me inspired me like I'm trying
to get people to practice reframing
their perspective bingo like I've come
to realize and it's so intense like you
can't even feet like only now am i
tapping into feeling it I'm like oh I
practice gratitude every day yeah I
Pratt you know that whole thing I make
pretend my kids and mom dot write that
whole thing got to be practicing suspect
I'll hear established a daily practice
in future world with meaning and Stussy
toward in life and working life so they
it really by the way you're selling
books right now
good because I'm telling you right now
my audience is making I can feel it I
can feel the people right now on live
making the connection point to a lot of
the principles that probably
subconsciously make them interested in
what I'm talking about and this is a or
Elaine within it yeah that I think and
you know it's funny a lot of people
struggle you know I've met with a bunch
of employees this week a lot of them
struggle with they are doing a tangible
thing but they all like I'm creative but
then it feels like that's fluffy dude
yeah let me talk about that so strategic
they think it's that we've been sold a
narrative that it's fluffy and it's
naive to follow your calling and that
it's if you are if you identify as a
creative it's a nice to have let me tell
you something every person that you
looked at look up to admire whether it's
you or Richard Branson or brené Brown or
your neighbor who lives in integrity and
is a badass every single one of those
lives was created all of those people
understand that they are creative
naturally and they put that to use and
so if you're wondering what the
disconnect is between what you're doing
and what they're doing first thing is
they have acknowledged their creative
second is they're putting that to use
every day and they are using those that
muscle to create their life third yes
they've practiced to embrace no yeah of
course they've got to say about like to
me this is like the underpinning in the
hardwiring to creativity is the courage
and lack of fear and ability to quantify
judgment
that if you're not capable of you're not
going anywhere I talk a lot about that
in the book is intuition so we've been
also that we've been sold a lot of lies
and there's no evil genius over here
telling us to do this but the reality is
culture wants us to be average because
it's predictable your parents they want
you to be safe here we play on this
ridiculous counselor they all want you
to do the middle and I'm telling you
this the riskiest thing in the whole
world to do is what everybody else wants
you to do chase what's really
interesting about this is it's actually
when you say that my brain went into a
place of negativity is louder than
positivity this is playing out yeah in
real data yeah yet more people are happy
than ever they don't fully realize like
there's so much interesting stuff going
on when it comes to this yeah there is
no evil genius school's [ __ ] totally
like that apps like the it's too rigid
yeah it's just - Rick what actually you
know what schools awesome for 33% of
people for sure it actually means that
there needs to be what we don't have in
school in modern times is the heavy
alternative for kids like us for sure
that's why I created creator we don't
have yes literally because there's no
there's no worthiness yeah like there's
no alternate and I don't scale
alternative right and the reactor's
homeschooling for sure there's there's
creative rogue parents yeah but there's
no macro system in place agree and also
if our parents had one job we'll have
five the next generation is gonna have
five at the same time high grade so
you'd be able to better be able to
acquire skills and all again all of this
you just take an array you can call it
went to personal development or
fulfillment whatever I'm couching it in
creativity you are in charge you have
agency over where you do a talking yeah
no please do you'll be great at it damn
I knew he was gonna say that you know
you're walking into that buzzsaw oh you
should have [ __ ] downloaded the app I
know I know I saw we got busy like you
saw from a mile away you're gonna crush
on it okay it's gonna work for you I
appreciate it you have a real mess a lot
of my friends and we do this to each
other they'll say things like you really
sound clarify this time like we're all
doing the same thing the creative the
people that are doing sometimes it's
easy sometimes it's clear sometimes it's
right like I'm feeling so pumped right
now because this is a very I'm real
maybe maybe it's our hypothesis our
matching at a current moment
you feel clear as [ __ ] to me right now
crystal because it's been a long time
coming it the books been in my brain for
like nine years and I've been working on
the photo books before to photo books
this is my first like ogee Anand yes
easy this is Gary Vaynerchuk and you're
on with Chase Jarvis hi man what's up oh
don't lose your mind and we're gonna
we're gonna get through this we're gonna
get through this what's your class
pleasure my friend
yeah I have a question so my question is
I'm a little the new creator so can I
give you a little bit of my background
before I take just no context please so
sorry
yes I I'm a marketer you know I've been
working in marketing as a corporate job
for the last 7 years but I recently quit
my job and was able to go full-time with
my own video marketing agency where I
help people create content for YouTube
and Instagram specifically and Hydra TV
nice job oh it's smart thank you so so
I'm a new entrepreneur but I'm also a
very creative person so it's it's a
growing up I would always consider
myself to be a very creative person and
creating content is like my outlet so
you know I have my one very small
youtube channel where I pre create
content but my dilemma is I know Carey
talks about document don't create but
then as a marketer I'm thinking you know
I need to make content that people are
searching for you know that doing the
SEO and that's that's good that's
because you're confusing marketing with
sales a marketer she or he is building
for the long term
your explanation as a marketer was
tangible and transactional mm-hmm
can you elaborate on that I sure can and
we will time you again or or
you're using the term marketer in a
modern world where we have in a lot of
ways over leaned into tactics and short
term ROI s you're trying to hack the
tangible search queries to create short
term views or macro micro very quick
mick micro not macro micro transactional
what you're doing is transacting and
selling which is being confused as
actual brand building and marketing
mm-hmm you're not gonna struggle with
where you were going with this question
once you understood that branding and
marketing is a marathon but right now in
digital marketing a lot of people have
made its trying to make it transactional
yeah I've never this is why I'm back
this is why I'm not as big only recently
have we even started somewhat trying to
get good at like search or I see you
like like we don't I've been on YouTube
since the get yeah and still have no
concept of titles and thumbnails for for
marketing I'm going so branding
marketing of continuous message at scale
yeah I'd say if you're gonna prioritize
something you got to know who you are
and what you're making and for whom and
why the other stuff takes care of itself
over time but if you do the other stuff
first it's backwards it's like you're
gonna go be a banker because your
parents told you so you need to look at
like what do you want to do and the
market all the little SEO all those
little nuts and bolts it's great if
you're if you're literally living your
life by the data exclusively then you're
gonna look like everybody else you're
gonna be fighting for the same search
terms and how are you gonna stand out
the only way you can actually stand out
is by being unapologetically
no-questions-asked you and my friend and
not what what ended up happening is it
even blended into the creative the
reason people continue to post the same
photos of their TNA or of their abs or a
beautiful place they went into is they
know that the likes are gonna be there
and it's limited the creativity on the
creativity part yeah not even on the
quant it
started in digital marketing on the
titles the math yeah but it's
subconsciously has blended into the art
itself
where people right now are posting on
Instagram things they have no passion
about but they know it will do well
quote do well cuz I do well a rack to do
a resume you well to the way he framed
up his first two things out of hundred
preside all those don't come out of my
mouth as a marketer which is interesting
if they take likes away the world's
gonna get a hell of a lot more creative
I'm pushing it's gonna blow em up and
then rephrase I'm pushing something that
I didn't think of kudos to them to
testing it in Australian Canada I got
wind of that I'm like this is [ __ ]
yeah I was on the make new [ __ ] but I
was trying to encourage people to be
brave
instagrams doing it for you yeah
everyone's mad at the algorithm they're
starting to learn how the algorithm
actually works they watch human behavior
you know they're by the way in sort of
taking away the likes not for their
health they're doing it because they
observed in data what I observed as what
I hear live in people were starting to
limit creativity yeah hey um do you uh
you know and honor youth like you you
understanding what we're putting down
here you think you're getting your
question answered I am yeah that's all
the I think it's a struggle between you
know that's a test that conflict between
this is what I want to put out into the
world I want to share my journey which
is you know I'm a marketer and new
entrepreneur and I know I was able to
quit my nine-to-five job finally after
working for it you know on the side
hustle for the last five years no I want
to show people how I did it yep well
that's that's your ticket right there
men because you know what that's your
story unapologetic question you Meyer if
you're trying to talk about marketing
there's a bazillion people talking about
marketing there's only one you you've
got your DNA you have your experience
that's the only way you can stand out my
man you cannot stand out and fit in at
the same time and you're only gonna get
there by being you and on what I would
tell you is this is why I push patients
so much there'd be absolutely no
conflict if you actually were willing to
wait do you does that make sense in on
do you see where I'm going with that
there's a conflict when you're looking
for short term ROI on vanity metrics I
know
no no it's I'm really proud of you like
I like the way this is going you see
where I'm going
what what what people what people may
not understand yet about what I'm doing
is the reason I have seven to eleven
things I'm standing on is you need them
all you need all those ingredients to
properly cook the meal the second you
take away patience and you buy into
everything else I'm saying you're
vulnerable the second you take away work
ethic that because you don't think
hustle is cool anymore you're vulnerable
the second you take away empathy you're
vulnerable I'm like what I'm putting
down based on what works for me and
others and I try to remind people that
as I observe them is the ability to have
all the ingredients there because once
you take one out the vulnerability comes
hearing you who's been listening and I
can see what you're putting down by you
quantifying what we've just been talking
about and adding that patient's element
immediately immediately eliminates the
friction for short term metrics yeah why
do you think I started with eighty
thousand subscribers on my youtube
channel or whatever it was Wendy Rock
and I started three four years ago or
four years ago five five years ago even
though I was the og of oh geez there I
went to bid ler I never paid attention
to it I never asked for one time on
those thousand episodes of Wine Library
TV to subscribe I did nothing right
because I was in it at that point for 50
years
you got this matter you got this if I
was to ask you you know my platform of
choice is YouTube I just love the
platform and I feel like I can create my
best content on YouTube so what would
you such as I have like about 850
subscribers right now but I really want
to reach more people what would you
suggest I do in terms of you know make
how much how much how much content he
put now all right now about 132 videos a
week how many let me let me ask you
something if you heard the thing fake it
till you make it I have yeah okay okay
just put that share on the shelf you
need to make it till you make it
okay you need to be putting content out
there you need to be unapologetically
you'd be making stuff every day
that is authentic to you that resonates
with your audience and tells your story
and until you start doing the
you're gonna be stuck and when you start
doing that two things are gonna happen
one you're gonna have a bunch of energy
because you're gonna finally be not
doing what your mother your brother your
friends all these other people telling
you to do and then to the world's gonna
come help you because they can sense
that stuff they can smell it when you
are doing you that's what G when you
just like stepped on the scene boom
that's like this guy no questions asked
he's doing him and that is really sexy I
mean sexy is like you know yeah you
actually mean it the actual way that hit
them seat viddler not that that dude is
an attractive man on video listen I
think I think the biggest thing here is
you're gonna have to get out of a
framework where your opening question
starts with I have 850 subscribers and I
want more that sentence is death yep
mm-hmm
what just or just this what story do you
want to listen to me this is a I'm gonna
go I'm starting to I'm in a very
interesting zone post vacation I guess I
could feel it like a lot more angles I'm
about to tell you something else why do
you think I put document on a pedestal
and try to get you to make the ROI the
fact that your grandkids are gonna see
it
is because I actually think everything
everyone's doing now when they're older
that is I predict 98% of the people on
earth that create content right now at
scale which is everyone by the way at
some level will be will that the best
thing that happens from it this is now
98% there's a guess arbitrary but this
is how I feel this is the number I'm
putting on it that the best thing that
happens is not they quit their shitty
job and start a huge company it's not a
viral moment it's not anything else
then in 54 years their granddaughters
gonna come up to them and say Nana I'm
just like you in 2021 you said this and
that's how I think to that that sentence
from because that's who you're gonna be
at 90 that's what you're gonna care
about your family and and so the reason
I'd try to put that on pedestal and get
people to understand how valuable that
is is now all of a sudden Anand
if that's why you're making content what
do you want your grandkids to see what
do you want the world to know about you
not hey how
I mean I'm obsessed with mr. beast I
think he's so talented and understanding
like one of the few things that does not
come natural to me because it doesn't
have day in day out community and
reading common just it never was that it
wasn't an app for the first eight years
YouTube so I have so much respect for
that but if you talk to somebody like
that it's still gonna be the story
inside I can give you a little bit
brother any hack that gets you from 850
to 1732 seventeen thousand it's a minor
league move the thing that actually gets
you there is the [ __ ] content totally
and let me I mean I'm gonna I'm gonna
throw something you you talk about
document don't create and I'm gonna I'm
gonna just put a little twist on that
because it's all creating and why I
believe in you tell me if I'm putting
words in your mouth that you don't
believe is that what you're really doing
when you're saying document don't create
is you're trying to take the anxiety out
of sin rating because right now you're
going like oh I need percent yeah I need
to create something you want to hear the
best part of that whole little thing the
only thing I consume is documentaries
yeah not that that's exactly for
somebody was funny when you said that
that's exact
I'm trying to eliminate the barrier the
barrier totally just got which is what
caught me to the fluffy [ __ ] that I'm
not necessarily all elicit totally but
that's what I'm trying to do here is
like I'm trying to take the barriers
away from creating and I'm saying like
you have this engine inside of you right
now you're trying to say you're trying
to calculate stop calculating this
shit's not out there it's in here man
and you've got it
I just want you to start now [ __ ] you
up yep yeah yeah I can definitely say
I'm very paralyzed by just overthinking
things instead of just creating content
because you're putting because you're
putting metrics as the North Star
anybody who's putting metrics follow
count likes and data as the North Star
are inherently stuck creatively you
overlay or anxiety and insecurity of
judgment which is the comments and
you're [ __ ]
which is why 99.99999% of people are not
winning here's another thing man you you
I can tell just from how you're asking
you want a map you want a dot you are
here you want dot dot dot and you want a
red Xs where you're going you want to
see the whole picture
I'm telling you've been sold Maps
they don't exist they're not real all
you have is a compass brother you have a
compass and that says if you're
listening to what's actually in here
this compass says go north and as soon
as you go north that starts feeling
right it starts feeling good because you
all you don't have these maps we have
intuition we have what our soul is
telling us to do who we are that's why
he says document not create because
that's about you and that's what you
need to be doing right now not trying to
end follow someone else's math and for
everybody following along what chases
analogy was was awesome he's not talking
about a compass in holding it in your
hand when he was saying that I was like
oh yeah I'm gonna throw the [ __ ]
compass in the see blindfold my [ __ ]
self and walk through the [ __ ] jungle
and if you think a Panthers gonna get me
you're wrong because the compass is
inside 100% you got I'll punch a [ __ ]
Panther in the face and then you got
that come on punch Panthers in the face
hung on and if you didn't follow that
analogy here's what I mean there's
always gonna be big bad things in your
way the reality is is like I don't know
if the Panther Panther probably killed
you but I've always been fascinated by
the hacks you know one of the best memes
going on in culture right now is people
showing people how things are made like
that cashew thing the other day blew
everyone's mind blew my mind like what a
[ __ ] cashew look I would have been
living under a rock I don't know we're
talking about yeah there was there like
there was a thing that kind of went
viral a couple days ago that just showed
pictures do you know what cashews look
like when they're being grown they like
comment on your [ __ ] Apple thing like
what the [ __ ] like there's a lot of this
[ __ ] going on I've always been
fascinated by the things they tell you
to do like aren't you supposed he
supposed to punch him already supposed
to not what are the hacks for like a
bear or a lot there's all these weird
hacks all right yeah what you're
supposed to pay dad chase look at this
yeah I didn't see that I didn't click on
it what I was like okay I get it
sewn on right that's [ __ ] crazy
cashews a weird [ __ ] I love this Alec
Alec Alec or Alex Alex what's up name's
Gary B you're on with chief Jarvis hey
hey I had a question for you about the
creative muscle because I heard you
talking with Tyler Babbitt yeah I'll
give that like a break or
keep pushing harder well how do you
build muscles in real life man well you
just keep going at it but I but they get
sore you know yeah they do they do get
sore and then what happens the next day
you're a little bit stronger right hey
if you could live in I mean there's
there's a little bits of rest I get it
but no actually that's right actually I
think it's perfect yeah I actually do
think there's a lot of day that says a
rest day matters for sure and I think
where you're going Alex and where you're
going chase you're both saying the same
thing what chase is saying is one day of
rest yeah like go see your aunt yep you
know go snowboarding go watch netflix
for eight hours but not one month
totally but not one year watch some
great youtubers right they said I'm
gonna get great youtubers their content
out every day and they do that for a
year and they're like oh my god I'm
super crazy crazy burned out they take a
couple of days I advocate just a little
bit here and there and just keep going
I'd rather
hundred-person how to rest just a little
bit than to quit no this is exactly
exactly yeah what's up brother you just
come back stronger from it yeah of
course you do and that's like this is
not this is not some weird new science
that I'm preaching this is like
practical as hell that's the thing about
creativity people we thought it's like
naive no no it's literally the it's it's
we are creating machines everything in
the world everything in this room all
your thoughts are all created and so you
might as well get good at creating Jase
yes sir everything we think humans have
been around for so long
everything we do not have a singular new
idea we did get lucky enough to be born
first know everything just wasn't
documented you feel people broke through
yeah yeah so that's why I'm just working
on putting out my content and then
getting my podcast started so I just
come by the way my layouts real good man
real quick my favorite word in order
getting started makes me smile always
post it tomorrow start it keep your name
yeah yeah just making like everyone's
like I'm about to get my podcast started
what yeah dude there's something called
anchor [ __ ] put it out tomorrow
yeah yeah and that's why I just got all
my equipment
I'm getting my graphic no no call you
out man no call yeah [ __ ] we have a
phone are you talking on a phone right
now yeah you have to sleep man bro you
have all your equipment right here Ian
don't be that tennis player that buys
all the best rackets and all that [ __ ]
and then gets smoked by the guy that
comes out with a wooden rack and goes he
[ __ ] place tennis though I got the
kid that d-roc recommended on Alex let
me tell you why I'm positive you're not
gonna be successful if you care way too
much about d-roc and babban I'm kidding
I'm kidding I'm kidding
hey but I also like this is your hey
Alex Alex one second sorry to interrupt
sorry to interrupt you bud so I want to
talk to you about something real quick
and it's it's something I talk a lot
about in the book because what you're
going through what you're thinking what
your your mindset right now about I got
to get this and that and all that stuff
that is a procrastination that is
avoidance and and you're avoiding out of
fear because if you actually start
you're gonna see that your first podcast
sucks and then your second one sucks and
so all the tea rocks little [ __ ] kit
is not gonna change that all this funky
rock [ __ ] if you say if you say kit
won't take it one more time but if you
say kit when we're [ __ ] II Rock yeah
hey Alex let me let me just get one
crystal-clear idea across to you and
then everyone can yell at you on the
phone again and that idea is and I talk
about it a lot in the book that we are
obsessed with intellect we're obsessed
with thinking things through we have
journals to write stuff down we have
kids to buy we have shopping lists to
fulfill and you know what none of it
equals creating none of it none of it so
you need action my friend action you
intellect okay yeah can I ask you a
question yeah unsub real [ __ ] how do you
deal with feedback is there some nerves
that it won't get enough just be
realistic if you want to win I need you
at your Ross forum do you feel like I do
love feedback I think failure is the
best way I feel like people are afraid
to tell me where we start they just kind
of try to hesitate
tell me that I'm not I'm doing okay but
I'm not sucking looks like I need to
hear that because that's how I learned
from what so like so why why aren't you
making more just on your phone what
would be your thought with my phone I
just feel like I wouldn't be able to put
out quality content stop being solid E
stop but if it's subjective what you're
doing is you're limiting yourself on
overvaluing production value I'm not
getting into the story I'm gonna give
you I'm gonna I'm gonna feed you your
own medicine you know that that talk
that you just referenced me and Babb and
having yeah made it with my phone how's
that broke and I got a better one
I made babban your what what I love that
you're saying is that you're you are in
a particularly universal you're a story
that so many people tell themselves and
that's why you've been incredibly
helpful on the show to be vulnerable and
say here's what I believe I need all
this I need X I need why you need action
over intellect man you need to get
started and this is the number one thing
that keep people from tapping into their
true self their true creativity is that
they're worried they're all this other
stuff you just need to start doing it
and you know what when you start doing
it it's sexy you have to sexy that's
true don't talk keep going no more
talking don't say kids are saying
everything right you're saying
everything right the far majority of
people right now on the internet are
saying everything right the gap is
between you see where I'm going Alex I
love how you reacted to that brother
thank you you see where I'm going and
you thought you fundamentally have the
words down you can you can regurgitate
everything to me perfectly I've tasted
from a mile away I've been listening
like you've got the words down you're
just not acting on it action baby yeah
that's hundred percent Gary and I
understand believe on that I'm gonna
just do
yeah well this and listen you know
what's cool about moments like this why
I love doing this
my hope is here we are the three of us
right you
listening to you talk about d-roc bab
and things of that nature chase what
babban like I'm hoping like I'm hoping
like you're like [ __ ] all these people
that are putting in their phone numbers
I got through maybe that you know people
sometimes they're looking for that sign
we all are doing that [ __ ] yeah all
different versions
I'm just desperately hoping that you
decide this is the sign that you broke
through that chase and I you know I was
laughs I'm always wondering what
somebody who's never seen either one of
us chase or watching this right now and
like saying oh these guys are dicks and
I'm always that man we're so doing the
best thing right now trying hard we're
trying so hard right now to help okay
just want you to win yeah like not
trying to make you feel bad
trying to make you [ __ ] win bro yeah
you've got it you've got to decide what
the mental unlock is and that's why it's
either a fear of judgment listen your
your your point of view on quality chase
couldn't have said it better it's an
excuse to not make yeah so that's why I
go to the next place after he set up
that move I'm like okay let's dance here
cool you have an excuse to not make
that's firm you works you're not
interested in making that's firm for
everyone who's listening and for you
Alex next why almost always almost
always it's insecurity you know right
almost always your dad's gonna say you
should get a real job your girl wants
you to get a real job you you genuinely
don't know how to deal with negative
feedback because you were over coddled
and you always thought you were great
and then you woke up at 20 and said oh
[ __ ] maybe I'm not I was tricked you
overvalued school and really leaned into
grades and became a binary human that
thinks that a and B and C completely
dictates who you are there's a million
reasons why that's kind of percent and
you just gotta go for it right you know
but what I'm most worried about from
here but what I'm most worried about is
you're now in that middle spot where the
words or the justification right even
the way your answers answering here like
the way you're answering is like you're
in that middle spot where you we're
subconsciously saying it makes you think
you're doing it yeah you only people
might
you're saying it or sharing it and that
makes them think they're actually living
it well I feel like I'm trying to do it
I don't know I [ __ ] trying broker we
notice enjoy Alex like for real for real
what like when you talk about
perspective on life and you drop that
MIDI on if you can lose someone and the
next day like I that happened to me like
I lost my dad overnight and I think
that's kind of like where my
insecurities started and where my
perspective and my position how old were
you brother
24 hey tell us a story
Alex right yes all right Alex so my
second grade teacher told me I was
better at sports
then at art so I ran to sports and then
I did very well so she was in a sense
right but I denied my creativity for a
long time and then not dissimilar to you
instead of your dad passing away my
grandpa dropped dead of a heart attack I
was given his cameras and it was only
when I was given his cameras that I have
a chance and just that moment of grief
to look back and say man I've been
denying this part of myself for a long
time so use and these traumatic moments
in life they they have a profound effect
use that moment of reflection to decide
what you actually want with your life
because I'm telling you right now your
dad would want nothing more than for you
to do the thing that you want to be
doing and that's the number one regret
of the dead and dying people who are on
their death bed is that they live the
life that other people wanted for them
not their own so use this as an
opportunity use this as an opportunity
to seize your life define the way you
want to live and take all the other
shoulds they're never gonna go well it's
always gonna be a [ __ ] Alex do it for
you but yeah my mom went five and she's
the greatest mother of all time my dad
lost his dad at fifteen and he went on
the offense to provide to be a 24 year
old man and lose a father is devastating
to be a 24 year old man and lose a
father and then finished the sentence by
saying my intuition right now in self
observation is that's when my
insecurities started meant that you were
relying on your father too much yeah
yeah 900 percent believe that because he
started his own restaurant and it was
all about family and it just kind of
went down the hill promoter yeah but
this is let this be a great lens Matt
yeah Alex keep going that was a big
turning point in my life because it was
like we had to go through all his stuff
and that's why I was like wow
because he was big into garage saleing
and all that and so it was just a big
moment in my life where is like I really
need to figure out who I am and what I
need to do do you believe that you were
playing within his framework that you
expected your dad to keep taking care of
you you were gonna work in his business
he was always gonna be there in tough
tight like where was your mind at that
point
cuz that's what it sounds like you know
I wasn't working at his business like I
was doing my own thing doing h-back but
but you you was the one that kept our
family together and was doing I was like
you know bring us to breakfast he was
the center because he started his own
restaurant and all that yeah look
brother let me let me say this what I
think is so amazing about the world
right now is that the the internet which
is grossly underrated has brought us
together at a level that we've never
seen not even close we all know so many
more people right now currently in our
society we're spending a lot of time
looking at the negatives that's the
current vibe when chase and I were doing
social it was in back of the day was
nirvana yeah it was like oom bye [ __ ] it
it was hippy [ __ ] yeah now it's it's
cliche humans do this with everything
right now we're in the part where we're
over scrutinizing over judging each
other everyone's pointing figures we're
pulling each other apart
however this moment right now is you're
talking this is what this is what I live
for
like the humanity capabilities that we
have by having these things you're where
are you again
physically Spokane Washington right like
think about what we're doing right now
thousands of people are watching us
online you know from all over the world
you're in Spokane we're sitting here
we're talk like like brother you have
your whole life in front of you
yeah and I feel like a hundred percent
grateful for like the positivity that
you guys put out there and that's like
what's always helped changed my mindset
so do us do us the greatest favor you
could ever which is take that and start
doing things because because the word
you know nothing feels better to me than
when somebody stops me and gives takes a
selfie or writes me up manifesto but I
always leave thinking I hope they're
doing it yeah you know like yeah there's
if nobody ever said another nice thing
for to me a accolade a stopping me oh
you know some people are very kind of
like chill a wink
that's an acknowledgment which I value
just as much as a selfie yeah if nobody
ever did that again yet they all did I
would be four thousand times happier I
just want you to do bro like everybody's
got adversities you know that and oh
yeah and I just I believe in you're like
like I can you just feel you've got this
you [ __ ] got this bro you're gonna
live three more full lives and let me
give you a news alert you're gonna have
bigger tragedies than what you're going
through right now
yeah and I believe that you know that's
why I'm just grateful for the years that
I had with my dad and all that so I just
got to keep pushing a hundred percent
and you've got a got to do it for
yourself and your future life know that
the answers are in you men you have all
of the information you need it's all
right there
yeah a hundred percent trust thanks for
letting me ask my question respect man
before you go what do we have a prayer
of you making a video and putting it out
tomorrow
well tell me the true hands-on like for
my podcast no no no sure any can you
will you put out something and let me
ask you question oh I put out something
everyday on my Instagram okay I work on
Facebook and all that yeah okay and what
do you what do you want to happen in the
end I'm sorry I'm standing on this Jase
I'm just you know I'm just trying to I
build the community around spoken and
all the local businesses because I think
there's a lot of potential over here so
that's what I'm just trying to work
towards hey I'm gonna ask a favor I
wanna let let Gary and I each give you a
prescription
we're this is like doctors moment here
okay so G want you want to tell him one
thing he should do and then I'll just
happen in the face so my ass for you is
this if you made a video as soon as you
hang up you turn your phone and pointed
it at you and you've told the story of
what just happened about you got in on
the cult of the call-in show started
talking about this book and and you you
you shared with your community the real
[ __ ] you're going through and you put
that out because it's gonna look a lot
different than all your other Instagram
stuff right because you got what's your
Instagram while Chase is talking May 23
May 23 can I ask you a quick question
it's very important please tell me
twenty-three isn't because of Michael
Jordan but don't lie tell me the truth
it's a hundred percent because of my god
okay that's fine it's fine but just take
take it can be fine on your [ __ ]
platform it's not [ __ ] fine on the
askgaryvee show it took everything for
me not to hang up and I was right there
I'm trying to evolve too but [ __ ] bro
you're in Washington Shawn Kemp Gary
Payton bro
Kevin Durant if they moved [ __ ]
Jordan does sting a little bit I'm not
gonna lie as a sonic Lloyd [ __ ] hey Alex
do me a favor and make that video but
like I won't turn the phone to yourself
make that video and post it and I bet I
bet it's amazing a 23 that's my
prescription great give it a shot and be
real say yeah we got talking about my
dad and it hurts and I realized that I'm
living in his shoes a little bit I need
to break out whatever whatever is true
for you say that all right thank you
I'll take that advice okay no here's my
advice oh god here we go
for someone yeah I'm gonna follow you
back amazing a23 as a matter of fact
everybody's watching and listening
please go following follow amazing a23
right now an interim he's at 4:04 let's
I'm sure we can get the what's that
alright calm down
um we keep d-roc I just we just had a
manifesto of not putting metrics on a
pedestal and you're like jumping up and
down for nine more followers that was
establishing contacts after you jumped
around like it was [ __ ] Christmas for
nine followers amazing egg I need you to
go back tonight and right before we go
to sleep give a lot of thought to why
you think you love Michael Jordan and
I'm gonna explain why and I'm not
[ __ ] kidding
I think there's a lot of insight to that
stuff I believe there's a lot of insight
to people following LeBron or being
Golden State fans or being a fan of Tom
Brady when you live in Houston and
should be a Texans fan I believe there's
a fascinating fascinating underlining
thing going on in the world as a matter
of fact safe you putting you putting out
photos with my sneakers on like on your
account you can't you can't arrived on
your own self-esteem from other people's
success yeah it's safe you're playing it
safe man and it's understandable because
you've been told to play it safe you
said you're supposed to do this and that
and all the instructions we get and
their dad yeah Michael Jordan yeah me
I'm telling you see Ron go another night
and think about all that I've watched
you take Mike I want you to take my
clouds and dirt limited ation dark skies
that you're wearing in your photos and I
want you to put them on eBay and I want
you to sell them hundred percent I'll do
that right now I want you to then DM me
the link okay I will okay that's my call
to action all right take care
chase yeah man listen that was one of
the great things Caleb's [ __ ] crying
I'm I'm in a very simple place if you're
listening or watching right now order
three copies of creative call and give
them to people you love I really really
want chase to do well here because
listen I think everybody under
the economics and book deals or secret
deals or wine deals are not the variable
it is the competitive spirit of him
wanting to you know when I call next
week and be like bro I sold 10 times
more than you the first week he's a
Warriors trying to win out there so I
want to hedge that so it's only half as
many as I did that's a lot of three
copies instead of take about three I
really appreciate you thanks lemon love
you and you love your community thank
you I'm gonna say couple shoutouts on
the way out here for the people in the
community on Facebook who've been
watching Mike McDonald what's up Beverly
Sankey what's good
JB fellow tuber I love you thanks for
listening Robert Crowe thank you
Nancy Somers you had some great comments
by the way Nance John Muhammad Al Marah
Zook I love you Tim gallon back back I
love you thanks for all listening
SIA